avec loïc prud'hommes député france
insoumise de gironde
monsieur prudhomme bonjour merci d'être
en direct avec nous sur rt france alors
la loi sur l'état d'urgence sanitaire
n'a pas été encore promulguée le
gouvernement doit rendre sa décision
aujourd'hui de quel oeil
voyez-vous ce timing un petit peu
hasardeuse
écoutez vous avez employé le moins
hasardeuse c'est ce que l'on dîne sur
sept ce plan d confinement ou une date a
été décidée par un seul homme et tout le
monde a essayé de se caler sur cet
agenda et on voit qu une fois de plus ce
gouvernement d'amateurs n'a pas n'a pas
réussi puisque la loi n'est pas
promulguée que le conseil
constitutionnel donc rendra sa décision
ce soir et que en attendant
effectivement la liste de la crise
position sur les 100 kilomètres sur le
fichier médical et sur les attestations
pour les transports notamment ne sont ne
sont pas une réalité ne sont pas une
réalité les gars ne sont pas promulgués
et donc on se trouve dans un espèce de
flou où finalement c'est le la loi
d'urgence en intérieur qui selon moi
s'applique encore ce matin et pourtant
on a des gens qui sont dans une phase de
déconfinement qui est voilà une
impréparation une fois de plus on a un
gouvernement d'amateurs et c'est assez
inquiétant nous on avait également
emporté avec 60 députés un recours
devant le conseil constitutionnel parce
que ce nouveau projet loi d'urgence le
porter quand même des dangers graves
notamment sur l'absence de contrôle du
juge des libertés et de la détention
pour les mesures d'isolement sanitaire
est également le fichier médical qui
échappait à tout consentement des
personnes et qui manquait de contrôle et
donc on sait à quel point les lois qui
les lois d'urgence et les dispositions
qu'elle contienne finissent toujours par
passer dans les lois ordinaires et tout
ça nous inquiète vraiment beaucoup et
donc j'allais dire se rater de ce lundi
matin est une alerte de plus sûres sur
ces inquiétudes que nous avons d'une
manière générale vous parliez justement
de ses déplacements au delà des 100 km
mais également les
les attestations dans les transports en
commun vous y voyez un risque pour les
français écoutez le fait que la loi
n'est pas promulguée
je vais dire ne change rien à la
présence du virus ni à la façon dont il
faut l'aborder on savait que ça serait
le chaos ce matin dans les transports en
commun et j'ai quelques retours de mes
collègues parisiens notamment où on voit
que sur les métros les erreurs il y a
une influence incroyable avec une
impossibilité de garder cette
distanciation physique nécessaire pour
éviter que le virus se propage et donc
il aurait fallu préparer cela
différemment calibrer les transports en
fonction du besoin et du nombre de
personnes qui s'y trouvent
et puis tout ça en fait et le dire
l'aboutissement de 55 jours
d'atermoiements et plus que ça puisque
ce confinement long mais que le résultat
d'une absence d'une politique vraiment
très très fortes en termes de production
de masques les productions de tête qui
aurait permis de gérer cette crise
sanitaire tout à fait différemment et je
pense notamment à l'exemple de la corée
du sud qui avait une qui a eu une
stratégie différente avec des résultats
sanitaires bien meilleur excellent et
voilà je pense que on est encore dans ce
tourbillon de l'amateurisme
du gouvernement l'elysée et matignon qui
en appelle à la responsabilité des
français est ce que l'on peut faire
confiance justement la population après
presque deux mois de confinement strict
j'aurais envie de vous dire que
finalement il y la clé plus responsable
dans cette affaire ce sont bien sûr les
français puisque ce gouvernement est
incapable de nous protéger et de prévoir
donc on a vu que les français ont été
très très disciplinés et dans les
mesures de confinement même si je vous
ai dit c'était dû à la préparation de
cette stratégie de lutte mais en tout
cas ils ont compris que le niveau
sanitaire sa reposer sur leur
responsabilité puisque personne d'autre
qu'eux mêmes pouvait se protéger
puisqu'on avait pas de de masse
quantités suffisantes donc moi je suis
tout à fait rassurée sur le fait que les
gens autant que faire ce peu vont porter
des masques ou vont le garder une
distanciation physique la question est
ce que vous expliquez sur les transports
c'est qu'aujourd'hui malgré tout les
gens sont obligés de reprendre leur
travail puisque le gouvernement les a
obligés par les dispositions fin du
chômage partiel reprise reprise des
écoles pour que les salariés reprennent
le travail à la demande de leurs de leur
employeur et donc il m'est français face
à des décisions cornélienne reprendre le
travail et mettre mes enfants à l'école
et qu'ils deviennent exposé des vecteurs
ou ne pas reprendre le travail et puis
risquer de perdre mon emploi ou mon
salaire et donc tout ça et est
absolument insupportable ingérable pour
bon nombre de français et moi ça me le
ça me désole et ça m'inquiète que
preud'homme merci beaucoup d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes député france insoumise de
gironde